I'm giving you the example that
patriarchal like traditional patriarchal
mindsets affect you - you should 100%
get nine months off four if you decide
to have a child let me say this while
we're getting personal you should 100%
if you date a man who wants nine months
off leave him
all right so I'm very glad to have my
next guest it is first off anyone who's
going to be tweeting or texting or
messaging her I always want you guys be
respectful we talked about this anyone
who enters the arena as it were anyone
who was willing to engage in the process
of ideas with people across the aisle
it's really tough to get people it's a
lot of the time I mean recently so yes
so she has been tweeting me a couple of
times over the last week and a half or
so over the male priviledge is a myth
changed my mind segment and you can
follow on Twitter at Marea underscore
del Russo Maria del Rizzo how are you
I'm well how are you I'm doing well
thank you I appreciate you being on the
program thank you for inviting me and
not only that but you have your
headphones set up decent look she's I do
yes I mean your producer asked me to put
these headphones and so I have to give
you know I have to give props where
props or do what so no check later okay
so let's let's kind of get right into it
um I don't want it I want to make sure
that people kind of know our jumping-off
point how we made contact and I want you
directly your tweet so that I don't take
you out of context if I do at any point
please feel free to let me know
so the initial tweets that I saw for me
this is from the male priviledge of the
myth changed my mind segments we did was
that last Monday maybe - I don't know
was a while ago it's irrelevant we don't
need to get into this information but
you tweeted me the fact that you expect
people to walk up to you and hand you an
explanation because you asked for it
instead of going online and researching
it yourself is a pretty perfect example
of male privilege there are a couple of
tweets but let's let's start with that I
don't know that I necessarily agree with
the premise or understand it but sure
well I just want to apologize for that
in advance because a lot of your
followers did tweet me ask the fact I
didn't
know much about you or that this was a
thing that existed beforehand I did not
know that the change my mind segment was
actually a thing so now I'm aware of
that but Before we jump into all of this
I'm hoping that we can kind of start it
out just as kind of like to frame off
our discussion to kind of define what
privilege is because I think that that's
where a lot of this tension comes from
right so there are two definitions that
I want to share with you so the first
one is from like good old Webster's
dictionary and privilege as defined by
that is a special right advantage or
immunity granted or available to only a
particular group or person right if you
talk about privilege in sociology that
examines these social economic and
political advances advantages it excuse
me given to a group on the basis of sex
race finances all that type of okay
great really quickly just so I can make
sure and so we're talking about systemic
privilege systemic discrimination versus
geological cultural and in what you were
tweeting me were examples I guess you
would probably argue sociological
examples of me language well their
societal examples of male privilege
sociology is kind of the study of how
privilege influences these different
systems so society is a system as is
economics is a system as is politics is
a system so the examples that I were
sending you were examples of social
privileges that men have okay but when
we talk about privilege from the top
about me specifically well I guess I
guess this would apply to to all male
state because this is how I made contact
so I do want to I appreciate your
apology and to change my mind thing um
it's a second we've been doing for a
while and I know you mentioned you got
some threats from people and some
terrible comments which listen I mean I
won't apologize from because I didn't
make them but I'm sorry you had to know
with that that's never my intention ever
and I know you you asked me you know as
a male if I'd gotten similar threats
from from followers if I'd been asked
that I would be raped for expressing it
if it I'm sure now that you've done a
little more research on who I am that
you're you're probably aware this is not
a privilege I enjoy yep yes 100%
I and again I I get all of that now but
the reason why I wanted to define
privilege to you is that a lot of people
consider privilege when we talk about
male privilege they think of it more as
like an adjective when in reality it's
actually a noun so it's something like a
privilege isn't something that you
necessarily or men in general are
necessarily you know exercising
participating ain't exactly exactly
exactly I know that one of the jokes you
like to make is there's no secret
patriarchy meeting coming together and
being like here's how we're going to
oppress women like sure men's rights
groups exist in this country and they
may feel that way but on the whole this
is not what this is right what we're
talking about when we talk about male
privilege is the fact that historically
men have been in positions of power and
because they have been in these
positions of power they tend to frame
the way things are and because of that
they you know they they have privileges
that women don't necessarily have and
that's sure I appreciate I appreciate I
want to make sure you have you have the
full we have plenty of time so there's
there's no right yeah because you've
just discussed men in power and since
they've been in power the structures
that be that provide privileges yeah so
that would seem an example of systemic
so let's start with that
and then get to societal can you give me
any examples I guess right now twenty
eighteen of privileges rights afforded
systemic systemically to males not
afforded it cool so okay so this is
again why I have a problem with the term
privilege I actually prefer the term
advantage over privilege because I again
I think that people get really caught up
in the idea of okay advantage privilege
but you just mentioned measure power
right so let's just let's go with this
all right white men in power in this
country for a long time mostly men in
power right now in 2018 there are a lot
of female politicians a lot of
minorities but let's so let's go with
that what rights since you run up people
in power these people in power right
they've created the structures that be
right now the structures that be exist
in 2018 any rights or advantages
privileges afforded to men
not officially afforded to women in 2018
well what we are arguing here is that
you guys are benefitting from a system
where you guys were initially the only
people in power right you guys have like
a centuries-long head start on us and
because of that these things don't
change immediately so sure women are
equal to men in that we can vote in that
you know women are just as able to
ascend to ce o-- positions in all this
type of thing all of that is available
to us but since men have been in power
for longer than women have had the
opportunity to be in power you guys have
a little bit of a head start on us and
we all know that it's very difficult to
change people's minds about something
right I wanna move on I just wanna make
sure that we both agree on the premise
no rights not afforded sure on paper
there are no rights that a man has over
okay to clarify because you mentioned
government systems of power and so
people will hear that in right away and
I do feel that a lot of the left do that
cont I'm not saying you're doing that
but as a bait-and-switch like well the
systems of power that be and so people
go oh wait hold on a second what rights
out there are unequally distributed what
rights are not afforded so we but we
both agree okay there are no rights
afforded to men not to women okay but
and then so everything is so everything
is societal everything we're talking
about today then is societal sure yeah
okay so this is why I like to bring up
like men in power men in positions of
power another term that we get tripped
up on a lot is the term patriarchy right
like I know that the right hates that
term patriarchy and I think that it's
because a lot of time just funny we
don't yeah it's it's funny but if it's
it's literally defined as a system or
society oh no a system of society or
government in which men hold the power
and women are women are largely excluded
from it you can agree that that is the
way things have been for most of history
right you and I can agree on that well
no not if we're talking about societally
no no I'm talking politically a system
of society or cover
so let's talk government right which
price so now we're going back to
systemic so systemically yes for example
women didn't have the right to vote
until men passed laws that they that
they could yes but I want to make sure
we compartmentalize those because we've
now moved on to society because even if
you go back then you look at the
temperance movement you look at the
influence that women had in politics and
you look at prohibition they had every
bit as much as of influence and power
they just weren't necessarily in
official positions of government so now
we're kind of blurring those systemic
and societal but see those lines the
arrows are not hard to find lines
because one hand washes the other when
it comes to this type of thing when it
comes to privilege it's all kind of
interconnected because patriarchy is
also defined as a system of society in
which the father or eldest male is head
of the family and you could you could
trace descent through the male line
right so it's all whether it's society
whether it's government men are in
charge okay so today again let's so
because again we're going into systems
of power and men who are in power today
societally privilege advantages we moved
on from rights societally how do you
make the argument you know like I said
this is a change my mind effectively
right now the idea that we're taught in
schools by you know gender studies
professors by far-left progressive
feminists this idea of privileges the
word they use you know I know everyone
has different words we that word that's
used when I was in college when we had
to read Naomi Wolf examples of that
today societally I would love to see
some some concrete examples to see if we
would agree or disagree yeah I mean and
I'm gonna keep pushing on this it's like
the fact that men have been the ones
empowered they are the ones who are able
to dictate what is what is what is truly
like I'm sorry I'm losing my train of
thought right now because I understand
what you're saying but what I'm trying
to explain to you is that these power
positions influence our society today
because we they do certain I agree with
ya of course listen your house your past
dictates a part of your present but you
know listen again
two people in positions of power they
made men eligible for the draft and not
women right they made men have auditory
bucket duty and not women they made
men's an actual whipping post if they
abused their lives and not women so you
know no one's perfect and if we talk
about patriarchy you will hear a lot of
feminists say that these patriarchal
systems are also negative for men as
well we're not just saying like we need
to dismantle the patriarchy just because
it's bad for women it's bad for men too
for all of the reasons that you just
agree that you just talked about so so
since you guys have had the benefit of
being in power for centuries that's the
norm and you and I know that it is very
very difficult to change the idea of
what is normal right like your producer
and I were joking before I came on about
the fact that you know we I have to have
two different head phones one for my
computer and one for my iPhone because
when Apple changed their iPhone jack and
got rid of it people like went nuts Ryan
that's a small change right that because
that's the norm that's what you're used
to so if you are used to seeing men in
power and if men are used to being in
power it's hard to kind of change that
dynamic and because of that like you
just assume that men will be in power
it's an assumption it's a systemic
assumption it's something that people
just assume is the norm that is the norm
someone once asked truth Gator Ben Bader
Ginsburg what is the what would make you
happy like how many women on the Supreme
Court would make you happy and she said
all of them because there have been all
men on the Supreme Court so why
shouldn't there be all women yeah see
that's where we differ and that's where
I think I think where we can come come
to our disagreement maybe later on we'll
continue along this path is the solution
see I think that's a horrible and I mean
I'm sure you can imagine why I would
think that's the worst answer possible
sure I I happen to agree with you but
the fact that all men is normal and all
female is abnormal is no but that's not
why that's not why I think it's bad I
think it's bad because I am all about of
course we support on this program equal
opportunity
what Ginsburg is talking about there's
equal outcome I couldn't care less it's
not because there's normal or abnormal
whether it's Clarence Thomas or Ginsburg
I couldn't care less I care about the
most qualified person for the job I care
about the constitutional scholar who
will protect our rights I couldn't care
less if they have a penis or a vagina
and I think that's a big reason why
young women and particularly young men
the dangers that we're seeing now reject
this idea of feminism reject this idea
of privilege and advantages because they
see a lot of disadvantages that men
experience not as a result of patriarchy
but as a result of feminism because of
that mindset that it's time to ensure
equal outcomes saying all women on the
Supreme Court listen if you're a man
today if you're a 22 year old male you
go hold on a second everyone here has
equal rights and I don't want the
Supreme Court to become an affirmative
action land but and I completely agree
with you it should not be an affirmative
action land and the people who argue for
against male privilege are not saying
that you should give positions to women
simply because they're women we just all
want to be treated equally and we're not
really at this point if you do that if
you can't ensure an all female Supreme
Court so you understand the subtext
there you can't I do 100 percent a
hundred percent I cannot guarantee an
all-female Supreme Court but what I what
the reason why I brought that up to
begin with it was to underline my my
argument that all all-male all the time
is the norm it's the norm that's a
hundred percent the norm it's been the
norm I would not agree or you just I
would not agree that all-male all now a
hundred percent is the norm you had
females in the Republican primary and
the Democratic National candidate was a
female I don't know that it's a high
percent the norm I just I don't agree I
believe it it's actually probably
disproportionately not the norm if you
look at the amount of women who go into
certain fields and then you look at how
many of them make it to the top whether
it's stand-up comedy or the field of
Sciences I don't agree that in 2018 it's
the norm to see 100 percent men I think
it's the norm I'm not saying that it is
the norm I'm saying that it's the it's
the assumption that that's what you're
going to see when people go
to the doctor they assume that it's a
male doctor when people go to a lawyer
they assume that it's going to be a male
lawyer because these are fields that
have been traditionally dominated by men
you know I mean I don't have their I
hate to I don't agree premise you don't
have to agree with that that's not
accurate like the medical field is it
the legal field yes let's do this we
have to agree on fundamental facts right
yes most lawyers are men we can get into
why that's the case but in the medical
field you have plenty of women obviously
people will argue many of them going to
nursing but you have plenty of female
practitioners who are doctors I've had
female doctors myself my wife has female
doctors I don't agree with the premise
that it has been the norm for a long
time or certainly today for you to
expect a male doctor I think you're
seeing you're seeing everything through
the prism of gender here and and not
through the prism of qualifications I
don't believe that most people go mykes
if a woman walks into their office when
they're on that deli papers and will
hold on a second you have breasts this
is not what I signed up for I don't
think anyone cares
I really don't I'm not saying that they
care I'm not saying that they're gonna
like get up and storm out if I look like
if a woman walks in interesting that
there are certain things where you
expect a man to show up and I think that
that's very represented and you could
even look at our own government only 19
percent of the House of Representatives
is female and there are only 21 female
senators sitting at this moment so you
know that's not equal that's not you
know all women it's mostly men and I
think a guy why do you think that you
know over half the country are women why
do you think that is why do you think
women aren't voting in the women well I
think that we're not voting in the women
just because they're women I think that
you know we I don't really want to get
into the whole Trump Hillary thing
Hillary did win the popular vote we
don't have to get into all of that right
now
you guy and we are voting in four we are
voting in women I think that
traditionally women have not been pushed
into or have not been motivated or have
not even really been told that they can
achieve situations like this because we
and we can get into sexism with this now
women
who enter careers like politics who
enter careers like anything where
there's a high profile tend to be put
through it like it's had to be
scrutinized a lot more than men I think
that's your view and that's well and I
and I don't think that's you know and
that's not statistically corroborate and
here here's my point this is what I
think it's so important the way you
reached out to me you said they exist
the fact that you set up as a male and
no one who wrapped this is a perfect
example of male privilege you saw that
and you assumed it was because I was a
male just like right now you're assuming
that it's because these people running
our female it's an assumption and it's a
thin in this case with me it was a false
one you immediately say well as a
Magendie
and I think you let me Lane alright well
let me explain my criticism on can I do
that I know that you you look like you
want to say something else but can I
explain my criticism of you so your
change my mind segment is an example of
you know the the lack of diversity that
we kind of talk about when we talk about
politics so I mentioned the 19% of the
House of Representatives is female
they're only 21 sitting female senators
right now right so the majority of
people who are making the decisions and
politics are men right empathy is hard
it's really difficult to know what
someone else is going through if you
haven't lived it yourself so it's
difficult for a man to understand
something that a woman has gone through
if they haven't experienced it
themselves like you can you can
understand that right you could do you
agree with that or no
no I don't agree with the premise that
it's difficult to empathize if I can't
empathize with the plight of someone
else because I haven't personally
experienced it I'm a sociopath well a
lot of people have problems with empathy
a lot of people like I can give you well
let's go back to what you're saying I
guess so before we get know you're
saying that was example so use my
example okay so your example so if so
your change my mind segment to me was an
example of setting up like this
typical privilege patriarchal system
that we have where a man isn't
we're in it's up to me as a constituent
to change your mind because you already
have an opinion on it right so you were
kind of putting together like a mini
version of what women feel like we have
to do since women and people of color
anyone who is a and a minority in this
for in this country it's not and who is
not represented has to change the mind
or you know advocate for themselves
because they are not represented
themselves so you know and you
acknowledge that your premise was
incorrect yes well I mean I still think
that we that setup is an imperfect set
up if you will take a little
constructive criticism I'll go ahead how
how should it be set up and also a big
guising by the way that it was set up
that way is because of females
repeatedly violently assaulting me I'm
sure if you've seen previous videos so
but how do you think it should be set up
so that it would not mirror
quote-unquote sort of microcosm of a
patriarchal system the change my mind
positioning is what really it's it's
more of like I have this opinion it is
your responsibility to change my mind
instead of being like hey let's let's
enter into a discussion like this you
almost like the word debate admit it and
then you have to catch yourself so let's
do it
so let me explain to you why and maybe
you'll maybe this will be illuminating
the change my mind segments by the way
are pretty popular it's the complete
opposite of cable news that's the design
behind this so we just recently had one
on pro-gun changed my mind and yeah I
thought this is and most the time
they're incredibly civil civil
ironically not the only time we've ever
had people violently assault or screamer
have have been feminists on campus they
haven't been the best ambassadors so the
purpose for this and by the way
understand that my view is the unpopular
view to hold on campus I'm going into a
campus or the vast majority of people
would agree with your presuppositions
and not mine and so I'm going into
actually not only neutral territory but
adversarial territory presenting a
differing point of view and allowing
anyone male-female black/white take your
pick
your guess is as good as mine whatever
gender walks along down the trail anyone
to
have a conversation the onus is on them
to present to me why I'm wrong because I
am taking a more contrarian view than
what's taught in schools because
everything you've just said I learned in
women's studies in college so the reason
why I took issue with it because it was
a male privilege thing is because as a
male you were saying I am male and I
think that male privilege is a myth
changed my mind
so you're asking me as a female to
validate my experience no I'm asking you
as a critical thinker
okay well the way it came across to me
and I know a lot of the people that I
follow on Twitter is that you were
asking me to validate my experiences
within Mel privilege which is why I
think that you got such a harsh reaction
well here's what I that's that's get
from Twitter feminists and there's the
microcosm you are really in an echo
chamber a bubble because you can look at
the like to dislike ratio you have
people coming and going listen I voted
for Bernie Sanders and this is what we
need more of is this kind of a
discussion the only person seeing it
through the prism of gender or seeing it
as an example of patriarchy which by the
way is false it is completely I always
show to be as civil as possible the
premise is factually incorrect are the
feminists on Twitter and I think the
reason you're seeing more and more young
women not identify as feminists is
because they feel increasingly
disconnected someone looks at a table
where they see someone sit down for
hours and they're willing to have a cup
of coffee and a conversation with anyone
and they see only the feminists saying
that's offensive for one to three
reasons or that's an example of
patriarchy 4xyz nobody outside of
Twitter feminists no one in real life
agrees with that campus and feminists
and so I hopefully maybe you can
understand if you look at it why the
overwhelming reaction was positive from
both men and women alike I mean I would
also argue that you live within and your
Twitter and your followers kind of exist
within your own echo chamber in bubble
you could completely disagree with me
and now because you're here well sure
absolutely and you broke through that
mold 100% I know that a lot of I know
that I as a Twitter feminist a
self-proclaimed Twitter feminist have
broken through into
servant of bubbles before as well so you
know I don't necessarily believe that I
just exist within an echo chamber I
think that we all surround our view does
your point of view does put it's very
very nice it's very it's a very small
slice and the reason I bring it up is
because you said I think that's why you
saw such a strong harsh reaction
I didn't less than 1% of the reaction I
mean across that board
I fed from Twitter femin okay from
Twitter hearts reaction but I think I
think a lot of you know a lot of blogs a
lot of websites as well there's a very
there's a huge disconnect between the
feminist movement the media who supports
them and mainstream Americans and I mean
left or right and so I would just like
to before we move on I think I'd like to
get to some specifics if we can would it
stand to reason that you know your
reaction was to say hey the fact that
you set up here is an example of male
privilege have you ever gotten threats
and the fact that you were incorrect
because the reason I set that up was
security getting permits yes I've
received death threats yes I'm on Isis's
kill list yes I've had feminists walk up
and take a swing at me so the fact that
you saw through that lens and we're so
incorrect I would like you to move
through this conversation accepting the
possibility that maybe you are just as
wrong on your other fundamental premises
I believe you are but I certainly want
you to present them sure I mean and I
I'm going through this hoping that you
may understand that you may be incorrect
on some of your fundamental premises
like I mean I think that I think that
that's what a discussion is I think that
you have to open yourself up to a
discussion like that I don't think that
I need to should be the only person
moving through this conversation no no I
don't I don't either I think you were a
little more aggressive entering into it
so that's why I wanted to make sure that
we clarified and let me clarify my
position I sure do I do not disagree
with the idea that there are advantages
that men enjoy in society I certainly do
not just agree with that just as there
are just a litany of examples where
advantages that women enjoy
I would actually posit that women enjoy
far more advantages in 2018 I feel like
that's and that's where the interesting
parts of this discussion is going to
come down and I'm really I'm actually
interested in getting and talking to you
about
type of thing because I think that the
things that you see as female advantages
are not necessarily so and I also just
want to say before we get into all of
that that in discussing male privilege
any you know logical human who who talks
about privilege and who talks about why
privilege should be gotten rid of will
never say that people who experience
privilege live perfect cushy lives
people who experience privilege suffer
all the time I'm not saying that because
men have privilege they don't suffer
like men are more likely I think the
statistic is from the Department of
Justice that men are more likely to
experience violent crimes from a
stranger that is a horrible statistic
and that is an example of how men suffer
but that does not factor into this
privilege discussion because women are
not because women aren't gaining an
advantage because you are getting killed
like experiencing violent crimes at
higher rates when we talk about
privilege it's a way that you have an
advantage that women have a disadvantage
on like it's so you don't believe and I
and that's not the only example I want a
hinge on that but you don't believe that
the fact that criminals select primarily
male targets for violent assaults you
don't believe that that is advantageous
for women well you all right so we have
to break that statistic down then
because I believe I don't have the
statistic in front of me I believe that
that the statistic is men are more
likely to be murder victims um by
strangers I believe that that's what the
statistic is I have to look it up
they're more likely the victim of
violent crime and I by the way also also
just as likely if not more depending on
the statistic of being sexually
assaulted so I mean this this list can
go on go down individually but yes all
of them yeah so and you said wait what
was the last part of the statistic and
also as like we are more likely to be
sexually assaulted in their lifetime all
right but I think that the statistic
that I'm looking at and
and we can compare statistics all day is
that women are though are actually more
likely to be victims of sexual violence
or domestic violence so like you we can
talk they're not though and they're not
when you account for the amount of
sexual assault that goes on in prisons
what um statistic are you looking at
this would go from the FBI or CDC I
believe but men when you include men in
prisons and car incarcerated men the
rate of sexual assault against men goes
up significantly sure and it's often
that is yeah it is often included what
but I what I'm trying to explain to you
is that privilege does not like that is
not a female prove that does not that's
not an example of female privilege that
we're murdered less because it's not an
advantage of ours like theirs it's you
making like the statistic that people
like to bring up a lot when discussing
male privilege is the pay gap which I
know is something that a lot of
conservatives claim is not a true thing
but it was the Department of Labor I
believe here I have it right in front of
me here the Department of Labor put out
us that statistic that said seventy
eight cents of every dollar is what
women make more they make that compared
to men and the numbers degrade when you
talk about women of color Hispanic women
black women they make less than that I
know you said we can argue about death
so we're blue in the face so I don't
wanna I don't want to take mine I think
it's think it was the Department of
Justice by the way but I'll take yours
because obviously I've let people know
there's nothing nothing up my sleeves
I'm not I didn't yeah you do that stat
modeling you're talking about right now
the seventy eight percent pay gap okay
you said it then degrades if you go to
women of color now let me take your stat
because you said okay it gets even wider
if you take women of color how does that
gap narrow why have virtually all
reputable economists said that it's a
myth because you just accounted for
variables very very intelligently that
women of color when you add different
variables you know that pay yet maybe
sixty eight percent but that pay gap
becomes four percent two percent zero
percent
sometimes a plus 1 or 2% for women when
what are you talking about different
industries oh not even just that see
that stat that you're talking about
simply takes the average income mm-hmm
of full-time working women versus men
now when you take into account not only
industry but more specifically job
more specifically hours worked travel
how long they've been in that position
that gap disappears as a matter of fact
there are new studies coming out
particularly in science and tech
engineering of stem where women make
more they're certainly admitted it
vastly higher rates because women choose
not to go into those fields so we now
have provided incentives for them to
where they actually make as much as men
so you can'tyou stats one way and say
well and then that gap widens if they're
black and then that gap widens if
they're well on a second that gap
narrows if they're both in a medical
field that gap is now non-existent if
the female and male are both doctors
working the same hours in the same state
there is no gap sure but you could alt
there are also statistics that show that
women are promoted less because
employers are afraid that they're going
to get pregnant and that they're not
going to stick around for all that often
they are not giving raises at the same
pace that men tend to be do like get
their women get pregnant more often than
men yeah but that's not something that
should be held against us because it
cuts both ways women are you know told
I'm sorry but I it's it's not something
that should factor into whether or not I
get a promotion about whether I may be
pregnant down the line how much money
you're lost or make the company should
not be factored into how much money I
pay you
you can god forbid get sick I'd have to
take a long leave of absence from your
company should that be factored it is
not a statistical 50/50 likelihood
sometimes more when you get over the age
of 30 that I'm going to get sick it is a
statistical likelihood that most women
this is where feminists disconnect from
most women want to make babies most
women want to have babies and so women
end up leaving the workforce for Italy
tonight I would I would argue against
that that is an opinion that most women
want to have babies I think that society
puts a lot of pressure more than men
more than men more than a hundred
percent because women are we are damned
if we do damned if we don't if we decide
that we want to have babies you just
said we're gonna be costing the company
more so we are not getting raises at as
often if we choose not to have female
not to have children we are as I think
it was who was that Senator here I
haven't written down it was that um
Portland psyche said that he did not
want his daughters to be career-obsessed
banshees so that is an example of the
idea of what women are if we choose not
to have children and we choose to pursue
a career we are career obsessing you
think do you think that's exclusive to
women you think it's exclusive one that
people hate their bosses no I don't
think it's exclusive to women you talked
about this Banshees yeah I think that's
actually I think that's a pretty funny
example I'd probably describe a lot of
bosses who I had including somewhat Fox
News as Banshees men or women screeching
banshees not big fans on but the point
is I think I just said damned if you do
damned if you don't I just heard that
women had a choice guess what a man has
damned if you do and guess what do
because we don't get to have babies we
don't get leave there isn't maternity
relief and I know you can point to
examples like Sweden in places where men
do a paternity leave and they don't
contribute anything other than
occasionally new form of birth control
every century but we're talking like in
the United States of America I certainly
would not consider that paternity leave
I think that you 100% if you and your
wife decide to have children you should
at paternity leave go for it yeah it is
well I guess it's a good thing that the
white men in power voted for maternity
leave and nine months off and nothing
for us so you can thank them for that
that is that is something that I
completely think that is wrong it's
wrong and I think that it goes back to
the fact that women you know again I'm
giving you the example that patriarchal
like traditional pay tree
our old mindsets affect you too you
should 100% get nine months off for if
you decide to have a child let me say
this while we're getting personal you
should 100% if you date a man who wants
nine months off leave him
okay that's not the guy you want
providing for you no I wouldn't do it
and I don't know any man who would who
would want to do it it'd be nice to get
a few weeks off you know maybe go down
to kawaii have a loo out that'd be fun
nine months off no but let me III
certainly I think you went to the worst
example right off the bat and I think
you'll see that most people don't agree
with you on that so let's go down the
list to other examples because certainly
I think you would concede we would both
agree there is an economic argument to
be made there as to why we're just
talking bottom-line dollars and cents
with pregnancy
that's not indicative of period overall
females in the workforce versus men so
let's remove pregnancy from the table
and move on down to advantages that I
that you believe are afforded to men not
to women so um I think that we've met
hold on let me get let me Center myself
now we talked about rape threats right I
got a lot of rape there's an odd
sequence let me censor myself
rape I appreciate that you didn't get
offended at that that was a joke so I go
ahead any any notes you have and I hope
so so you talk about violent threats do
you get rape threats I'm really curious
to hear yes particularly from Holmes
really yeah thousands per day thousands
per day from Muslims particularly okay
all right well you are someone I don't
know many men who get raped threats
right and to me rape threats ever watch
cause no one episode no Shawshank Green
Mile take your pick like the prisons the
prison system which is a completely
different conversation so what do you
know I think a man is saying this this
colloquialism aware a man calls a man
[ __ ]
that's asserting sexual dominance over
another male that's referring to male
female dog so my point is this st. these
same kind of derogatory terms and yes
death threats rape threats men get them
all the time as a matter of fact you do
sexual and I will concede this women are
more likely to get sexually themed
threats online and men are much more
likely to get violent threats online so
probably just because they're looking at
what gets under your skin
when you know when angry online jihadi
says that he's going to rape me I get a
chuckle I make sure he's not daxing me
and then I move along you know down down
the trail I know that upsets women more
so there's these are online trash it
upsets women more because it is a
legitimate violent threat towards us
it's something that you know and it's
not toward a man well you if you okay so
you're talking if you remove the prison
system because that is a specific that
is a culture that is not representative
of the culture at large it is a very
specific representative of matriarchy
I'll tell you that because men are far
more likely to be incarcerated for
longer terms for the same crimes as
women so I think it's pivotal that we
touch on that at some point in this
conversation we should touch on that at
some point but what I'm saying is that
if you remove that women are more likely
to experience sexual violence than men
okay can you concede that point to me if
we remove prisons if you if you remove
prisons sure yes I don't think you
should because I think we okay the
prison system for example and I think
I've heard you discuss this point or
tweet about it that black men are five
times as likely to be incarcerated now
what's like the pay gap right so you use
that but you don't account for black men
or that amount more likely to commit
crimes in men now that being said let's
go the other way men are more likely to
get longer sentences and more likely to
be punished and sent to prison for the
exact same crime as women yes and that
is an issue that's a sexual assault
conversation this is a trying to explain
what like men are women get raped
threats from men more than we get rape
threats from other women okay men get
rape threats and are raped more by men
than they are by women I'm talking about
the way that men and women interact with
one another here right so when we're
talking about privilege and we're
talking about all this stuff women are
more likely to experience sexual assault
from men then men are from women okay
and that you know you're describing some
of the workings of a patriarchy there
because for a long time men had dominion
over their feet over women's bodies
marital rape wasn't something that was
illegal in this country until 1993 and
to this day there are still some states
where marital rape is not tried the same
way as regular rape and it just shows
that is terrible listen you shouldn't
rape someone even if she said I do okay
we both agree on that I'm certainly not
a rape apologist but again you're
cherry-picking data and you do this a
lot you're not acknowledging that men
were also publicly humiliated flogged
beaten dragged to the streets if they so
much as laid a hand on their wife never
so if a wife takes a SWAT at a husband
so when we're talking societally there
have been different standards applied of
course to both men and women but both
enjoy different advantages and
disadvantages I'm certainly not saying
us as an example of today the society at
large favoring men I really would say in
2018 it's the opposite if you and I for
example if you and I go into the field
of Science and Technology
okay if you and I have the exact same
scores if you and I went to the exact
same school if you and I are just as
qualified you're getting a spot not me
are you sure of that statistic are you
100% sure that statistically yesterday
the statistical likelihood yes well you
can see that there are situations in
which if a male and a female are up
against the same job the male will get I
think I sent you one of these studies it
was the study and it I remember it if
you don't have it for anyway I remember
it it was a 2012 study yeah yeah well
study about I believe in science and
technology and and this was a very small
sample size about a hundred something
TVs were used and these were only in the
problem with it missing that feminists
use a lot
kind of like the pay gap they use a stat
that they know really isn't accurate and
they know it's not something that would
would hold water when it comes to the
court of arguments it's a very small
sample size the pay gap doesn't come on
you know that so let me this is a very
small sample study 2012 no it's not
going to hold water is just insulting
and is just it's just ridiculous it's
slightly so I'll give you that it was
slightly insulting I will give I'll give
you that it is but statistically it
still is something that put it this way
it is either startling that the feminist
movement at large have never read from
including female economists or it's
startling that they have and ignore it
it's one of the two but the statistic is
a statistic it doesn't care about which
group it's offending it's just not
accurate now when it comes to this study
if I'm not if I'm not mistaken I believe
it was a 2012 study that used very a
very small sample size and it looked at
people specifically in entry-level jobs
here's the thing feminists reached back
to 2012 to take that study but we have
other studies and we have meta-analysis
there was a 2015 study that looked at
the same thing I believe it used about
800 something applicants and when it
actually took into account people and
different jobs people you know becoming
tenured professors you know the salary
of a biology professor it actually found
that at higher levels of education women
in STEM fields were much more likely to
be accepted with the same parameters
this was a more comprehensive study it
included a larger sample size and it's
more recent I don't know why all of the
blogs and feminists on Twitter haven't
been able to find a 2015 study but it's
more valid and substantial and I think I
think that's important I'm not saying
I'm sure you weren't aware of it
I certainly am not attributing to any
kind of malice what I would at what I
think can be attributed to not knowing
but it is remarkable that a two-top 2012
study is still used to prove that point
is that the study that you're talking
about right now is specific to the stem
- like STEM industry - like those types
of jobs yes because I believe you sent
me the one the 2012 study on that that
was what you tweeted me okay so if you
want I can probably find it and bring it
up pretty quickly
it's I believe you it's not a you know I
completely yeah that's we and sure yeah
you don't have to look it up it's I I
I'm sure that it exists I will happily
look it up after I can I can yeah I can
I can send it to your we can put it kind
of in the description but yes there's a
towards a 2015 essay that included a
much larger sample size so okay so let's
just let's if we assume that I'm not
lying let's take that off a table so now
now that's gone alright so if you still
want to talk about jobs and you will
probably tell me that this is not it
does not hold water because it's
anecdotal there have been multiple times
that trans men have discussed their
experiences with privilege once they
have transition so when they were
presenting as female to when they were
presenting as male so once they started
presenting as male they would start
experiencing privilege like in their
day-to-day lives here a couple of pieces
of privilege that they have experienced
I'm suddenly funny no I'm sorry I didn't
I didn't want to laughter I didn't want
I didn't know if you were meant to okay
it's funny if a couple pieces of
privilege what the first point was I'm
subtly more funny the trans man oh I
thought you were I thought you were
saying it was a joke couple pieces of
privilege that they're suddenly more
funny that they're more that they're
taken more seriously that they rarely
get interrupted that they get paid more
clothing is more practical they get more
free passes they're not they're more
likely to arrive home safely after
walking alone at night they don't have
to worry about keeping an eye on their
drink as often as they did when they
were presenting as females they're not
told by strangers to smile
they don't have strangers giving
uninvited opinions about their bodies as
they pass by like just again that's not
surprising to me I mean I'm sure you can
imagine that a lot of those things
aren't because they're a man you you
don't think that it's how often do you
get yelled at when you walk down the
street
like hey baby like we know nice nice ass
like whatever like how often do you get
catcalled when you walk down the store I
don't have a nice ass so it'd be hard to
know oh I have a terrible ass I have a
giant a couple of things so first off
you're right I really am not super
interested in the anecdotal but I'll
entertain a discussion for a bit because
I do find it interesting I want to make
sure that I'm not misunderstanding
before we move on to this example that
you've used I'm not misunderstanding
kind of your position it seems to me
that you are arguing that because you
talked about patriarchy and how it does
not then it also is um sorry my mouth
get enjoyed it has negative
ramifications for men as well as women
it sounds to me like you're talking
about how gender is societal these
pressures to make these decisions to
look a certain way to act a certain way
to go into certain fields from what I've
been understanding gender is societal
gender is a yes is a societal okay
cotton strong okay good
yes I believe that so I asked us because
I'm confused please explain your views
on transgenderism meaning with genders a
social construct how can one be
transgender um I I don't believe that
there are many biological differences
between men and women either so I don't
really understand what you're saying
here and what's the point to being
transgender we're talking about because
they want to go through biological
transitions talking about hormones sex
change operations if gender is a social
construct this idea of transgenderism
not transsexualism you use the word
transgender would have to mean that a
male is born into the wrong body the
wrong gender the wrong brain and a
female is born into a male body so if
gender is a social construct
how can one be transgender or how could
you possibly support someone trying to
conform to the gender constructs as
created by society I don't necessarily
believe that they are born into the
wrong body I think that they're assigned
the wrong body at birth so I think that
you know a doctor burns a baby and he
sees that it has a penis he says this is
a boy right that's typically how it goes
it's a boy it's got a penis yes so they
are assigned that gender at birth so
transgenderism is you know is a size
identifying with a different gender and
why are we having this discussion again
because I don't understand I don't
understand how you can go to
transgenderism and talk about advantages
when you see the gender is a social
construct transgenderism fails to hold
up if gender is a social construct or
gender has to be biological it has to
you can't take a biological hammer to a
societal nail it doesn't make any sense
what logically does you can't be born
into the wrong gender if gender is a
social construct and that's one thing
that I find incredibly ironic for women
talk about feminists talk about we're
forced to live up to these expectations
we're forced to look a certain way talk
a certain way act a certain way then a
man says I've always felt like I wanted
to look talking act that certain way
really you look like a real-life Barbie
doll because you've had some estrogen
replacement therapy come on over we'll
accept you as one of our own transgender
men - women are basically pretending to
be every negative stereotype you've
talked about presented for women
societally it's actually can't believe
that we're having this conversation now
because it is completely bonkers what
you are trying to argue with me right
now okay just say that to say that a
person who was assigned the wrong gender
at birth and who had a lifetime of
gender biases pushed upon them where
they had to you know be hyper masculine
because they were assigned male at birth
because that they had to dress a certain
way when they didn't feel like that was
the way they wanted to dress they felt
feminine they're not they're not a
societal pressure which you seek to
destroy so that's a panel thing what are
you talking about I'm saying that if a
person is assigned male at birth okay
and they identify as female
they have the an entire life of female
of male like gender tropes pushed upon
them and but they identify as female so
they're they're choosing they identify
as female they're identifying with the
gender tropes thrust upon females do you
understand
again this it has to be consistent going
both ways I don't identify with the
societal pressures of being a male
I identify as female what do you
identify when it comes to being female
is it biology we know I don't believe
and we can go into this if you really
want to I don't believe that there are
many biological differences between men
and women really at all yes I do and we
can discuss this if you would like to
I'm probably not the best person to
discuss this because I was assigned
female at birth i identify as female i'm
cisgendered I'm straight it would
probably be who view to have a trans
individual on here discussing with that
many but yeah I know that you have but
this specifically so do you want to get
into this because it doesn't sound like
you do not I don't know that will make a
lot of headway so i'll you know dealer's
choice i do we do have to get we don't
have a ton of time because we do have
another guest to pre-tape actually from
from the high school in florida where
the shooting took place so i don't want
to yeah he's actually a but he would be
taking a contrarian viewpoint not super
thrilled with his classmates so I would
like you to let me ask you this it seems
like like you said we can talk about
that with a transgender person I don't
think well yeah ton of progress there
but I really hope the time to be in and
I mean I would put forth these examples
certainly in 2018 and I think if our
goal is to help people male or female it
would behoove us all to be honest and I
think that you have a lot of young men
and I think feminists don't really
understand how out of touch they are
with a lot of young men as well as young
women when you look at young young men
they go hannes like well we make up 97%
of workplace deaths we're three
something times more likely to commit
suicide we obviously are more likely to
be sexually assaulted were five times
more likely to be incarcerated we're
more likely to be incarcerated for the
same crime
we're
we are dominated by women at every
aspect of education from kindergarten
through college outside of SAT scores
they get more placement but as a
percentage of the population versus
percentage of people in college and
people who graduate I think you see a
lot of young men who are told that if
you tell young men to check their
privilege in an area where we both
acknowledge that they enjoy no systemic
advantages and we know that societally
they suffer from severe disadvantages
you'll see some very negative
ramifications within generation and I
would hate to see the pendulum swing so
far the other way because listen I'm
more traditional I know sometimes it
offends feminists but I'm married I hold
the door for my wife I believe in
chivalry I really do believe in treating
women respectfully and I do see a lot of
young sort of men's rights activists
going so far the other way now where
they feel as though they've been so
disrespected and their voices haven't
been heard that they respond
disrespectfully and I don't think that's
productive for anyone and so I think
truth is important in this discussion
above all else all I want to say is that
when people are talking about privilege
we're not trying to say that people are
actively acting in a way that like men
are acting in a way that makes that they
believe that they deserve more we know
that right from the majority the
majority of men are just behaving in a
system that tends to and you don't agree
with this Pat them on the back more than
they pat women on the back and by when
we say check your priveledge all we're
trying to say is acknowledge us
acknowledge our experiences you know I
know that you don't like anecdotes but
listen to women listen to what happens
to them and then maybe say hey you know
what I don't really want to live in a
world where I have to worry about my
girlfriend getting raped when she walks
home or like that she has to worry about
it and for the record I am happy when a
man holds the door open for me and I
will happily hold the door open for a
man as well that's just respect to me so
well thank you for and I appreciate how
respectfully you've been I hope that you
ulis has been a productive and back and
forth discussion even with disagreements
yes I do
okay and thank you and I do is well I
very much appreciate for ya voice sure
disagreements as respectfully as
possible I cannot apologize or take
responsibility for people with Twitter
eggs and for followers so yeah miss del
Ruth and I don't expect you to take
responsibility for your followers just
the fact that you're telling them
be respectful is well we always do in as
a matter of fact we did that what to
change my mind segments and and usually
the audiences is very respectful so
Maria del Rosso thank you so much for
taking the time I really appreciate it
and I hope I hope to have you back
genuinely on the program hey did you
enjoy this video here's the thing you
wrote your this is the end of it so we
don't care cuz you already watched it
but if you really didn't like it and you
want to justify it leave a comment below
telling us why you didn't like the video
and if you liked us let us know and
subscribe to the channel because that
lets the overlords at YouTube know that
you know what you're alright